[Music]
first peak of Angelina Jolie's Netflix
movie first they killed my father is
here the heart of it is long story it's
the story of a war through the eyes of a
child but it is also the story of the
country for the country what Angie is
doing is an amazing gift the film
centers on the hardships of a Cambodian
refugee in the 70s Angelina
directed it it's the first time there's
something on this size about this war in
this country we set the stage and we
explain like we did with this this very
difficult scene where we had to capture
the Khmer Rouge and beat him and we
found people who had either themselves
suffered or a new suffering the actress
is also waning on president Trump's
controversial refugee travel ban in an
op-ed for the New York Times Angie says
the policy should be based on facts not
fear and for her it's also a personal
issue many of her children were not born
in the US she writes quote I very much
want our country to be safe for them and
all our nation's children but I also
want to know that we can manage our
security without writing off citizens of
entire countries even babies as unsafe
to visit our country by virtue of
geography or religion
[Music]
Oh